viddy vous publiez baiser après mitu aux
éditions mare à bulles avec des
illustrations de digues les deux très
jolies illustrations il des films très
très bien les gens sont particulièrement
beaux et sexy en dépit du fait que ce
soit des dessins humoristiques
vous pensez vraiment qu'un tel mouvement
qui dénonçaient des cas de harcèlement
d'agressions de viol va modifier notre
façon à la fois de séduire et de faire
l'amour moi j'ai la sensation que ça
beaucoup rebattu les cartes jusque dans
notre chambre à coucher en fait j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya énormément de
sujets qui peuvent paraître et des
sujets annexes comme je sais pas
l'éducation des garçons des petites
filles peu importe la charge mentale
enfin voilà plein de sujets dont on a
parlé céda ces deux trois dernières
années va depuis octobre 2017
j'ai l'impression que le fait de mettre
tous ces sujets là sur la table ont
quand même beaucoup considérablement
rebattu les cartes des rapports hommes
femmes
et forcément ça a eu un impact sur notre
comportement sexuel sur notre façon le
baiser et surtout par exemple avec
toutes les questions autour du
consentement on n'a jamais autant parlé
de consentement que ces deux dernières
années enfin trois dernières années
d'ailleurs
enfin voilà donc oui je pense je pense
que ça modifie beaucoup puis surtout il
ya toute une génération qui est arrivé
donc ces trois dernières années qui a
grandit aussi en utilisant ces concepts
là ces concepts de consentement ces
concepts aussi de sotchi ming par
exemple qu'il ya un terme pour désigner
tout ce qui est discrimination
ostracisation des jeunes filles ou des
femmes pour leur sexualité et concepts
de même mon à part on parle de revenge
pampa il ya plein de choses comme ça
dont on parlait pas forcément avant et
dont on parle aujourd'hui
et moi j'ai l'impression que pour cette
génération là déjà ça ça change des
choses et grandissent avec des idées
peut-être plus je passais plus
égalitaire en tout cas plus respectueuse
et il ya une autre génération qui est
aussi la mienne en fait moi j'ai 40 ans
j'ai eu 40 ans ya quelques jours vous ne
souhaitez jouer cet anniversaire vous
ferai mais voilà j'ai eu 40 ans il ya
quelques jours et ni moi ils ne sont que
ma génération à moi elle s'est retrouvés
un moment face à un grand vide
pourtant mais moi qui baigne un peu dans
toutes ces histoires de féminisme toute
l'année au moment de nous tous et même
degree qui est donc les distraits
l'illustratrice on s'est posé la
question de
mais comment on fait comment est-ce
qu'on va réussir à d et maman
[Musique]